Christine Drazen joins me now Christine
now I came across this statistic and it
shocked me and I thought I had seen it
all but last year Mexico City
had a lower homicide rate per capita
than Portland Oregon so how do voters
keep validating that type of leadership
in this climate
well here's the thing it's not
uncomfortably close for oregonians
oregonians are reaching for change
because it's not good enough there is no
Universe in which the murder rate in
Portland should be close to the murder
rate in Mexico City and oregonians are
done they are done with it they're done
with the excuses they're done with the
poor leadership they're done with single
party control there is no amount of spin
that can cover up what it's like right
now in our Urban centers and across our
state oregonians deserve better and
they're demanding better yeah I mean
every time I look at sort of the news
you know cycle for Oregon now it has
something to do with some horrific
crimes that are taking place like this
morning it was a guy with wielding some
type of weapon I guess he had a rifles
trying to set fire to Mercedes the
police had to you know you know shoot at
him to try to stop this because they
were worried about explosions this is at
8 52 in the morning and yet you got
Elizabeth Warren out there you know
making a pitch to voters uh for your
opponent watch this
everything is on the line our
Reproductive Rights our health care the
needs of working families and our
democracy itself and that is why it is
so important to elect Tina kotek please
get that ballot in and vote for Tina
kotek for Oregon governor let's get this
done
abortion and democracy no wonder Eastern
Oregon wants to secede to Idaho with
that pitch
it's tone deaf it is tone deaf you have
to be completely oblivious to what life
is like in Oregon to come here and make
a national DC Elite pitch to Oregon
voters right now is completely tone deaf
oregonians across our state are talking
about kitchen table issues the things
that actually affect real people
inflation Rising costs Rising crime
lower quality of life across our state
and certainly education standards that
have plummeted under Democrat leadership
my opponent Tina kotec has been in
charge she has linked arms with Governor
Kate Brown in these last six years and
has driven our beautiful state our great
state of Oregon into the ditch and
oregonians themselves are demanding
better the fact that Good Morning
America would view it as dangerously
close is laughable uncomfortable and our
chance to turn this around is tomorrow
yeah uncomfortably close yes or no will
that ballot measure pushing for strict
gun control pass yes or no
I say no well that's the only one of its
kind in the country and a very odd uh
response to the crime rate going up in
your state Christine we are very proud
of this campaign you ran and we're going
to be watching this race very closely
tomorrow night uh best of luck to you
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else